Now we'll look at some example code that
can fit a line to data that's given.
Remember, we're using
a optimizer to do this.
And first thing we have
to do is describe for
the optimizer what is the function
it's trying to minimize.
So we'll call this function error, and
it takes two parameters, line and data.
Line is just two coefficients,
C0 and C1.
And data is just a list of data,
of course.
Well, we've got some nice comments
here that explain it, but
really, our error is expressed
simply in this single equation.
We have the value of the actual
data at each point here,
minus the estimate that the line
we're currently looking at
would give at that same point.
So we use the 0 coefficient, and
the 1 coefficient, times the x
value of the data at that point.
So we take those differences and square
it, and that's our error function.
And that's what we're
trying to minimize.
We've added some code to illustrate
how to use the minimizer to
find the equation of a line.
We start with our original line
that the minimizer doesn't know.
So, it's our secret, [LAUGH] but
we're testing it to see if the minimizer
can discover the equation of this line.
Here's the equation for our line.
It's just a two element array.
It'll have a slope of four so
coefficient zero is four.
And Y intercept of two.
So coefficient one of two.
Here we generate X and Y values.
Again keep in mind our minimizer doesn't
know these but we are just generating
them so we can look at them and we are
plotting them for looking at it later.
We take that original line and
we use from numpie the random
function to add some noise to it.
So at each point along the X-axis,
where we have data, we add some noise.
So, now we've got our original line,
plus some noise, and
we're going to challenge our
minimizer to find the equation for
that original line,
even though there's noise.
We wrote a separate function
fit_line that takes the data and
the error function we defined and
finds the equation for that line.
Here's fit_line it does that for us.
Two parameters the data, remember this
is noisy data that is approximately
a line and in other words we took our
original line and added noise to it.
And the error function, or
the function we're trying to minimize.
We have some nice comments here
that tell us what those are, but
now we just follow the steps
like we've talked about before.
We start with an initial guess.
Here our initial guess
is a slope of zero, and
a mean of the rest of
the data as our y intercept.
It could be anything really,
but that is a reasonable guess.
We plot the initial guess so
we have something to look at, and
I'll show you that later.
But here really is
the meat of the function.
You've seen it before.
So we call our minimize
function with the error_func.
In other words, this is the function
we're trying to minimize.
Our initial guess, and this is
a parameter you haven't seen before,
but this is a way by which we can
pass the data to our error function.
This is the method that
we're going to use.
And finally although it
goes off the end here.
We'll set display to true,
which will mean we'll get to see
any information as it goes along.
So that's it.
I mean really the key here for this is,
this minimize call right here and
then it returns the result.
So let's run it and see what we get.
There was some additional code that I
skipped over that generated this plot.
You can look at that on your own,
of course.
Okay, let's take a look.
Our original line is this blue line.
Of course the minimizer doesn't
know anything about that.
These green dots are our noisy data
where we just added noise
values to the blue line.
Now we're asking our optimizer,
okay find the equation of a line
that best fits this data.
The metric you're trying
to minimize is error.
So we passed it in an initial guess
here of this purple line and this data.
So that's all it knows right now
is this initial guess of a purple
line and this data.
And then it iterates and tries different
slopes and different y intercepts.
Until finally, it converges to this
red line and that's the solution.
And I think it looks pretty decent.
We can check it here, so
if you look in the code, you'll see that
our real line had a slope of four and
a y intercept of 0.5.
So we've got 4.17 and 0.64, not exactly.
But if you look at
the data you can see that
it's pretty hard to know exactly what
the underlying line would look like.
So, I think our equation
solver did a pretty good job.